wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some amazing
motivation from bill gates
do you have any regrets in your life you
seem to have a life that most people
would love to live you got a happy
family
great marriage foundation business
success is there anything can you make
us feel good by saying
you've done something that didn't work
out or just make us because all of us
feel bad because we look at you and we
can't
do what you've done so tell us something
that's bad that you've done or you'd
feel inadequate about
something it must be something i am
super lucky uh
you know the marion melinda
uh the experience at microsoft
that although it had its ups and downs
was uh
phenomenal uh the work of the foundation
and no regrets about anything i wouldn't
try and go back and change anything
i mean for example the anti-trust
lawsuit against microsoft
you know was bad for the company it
created a lot of distraction we would
have done a lot of things including the
mobile operating system better
if it hadn't been for that but in a way
it was a lesson for me
uh and you know so it and
it probably accelerated my retirement uh
by five or six years which overall for
me
probably was a a good thing um
you know i don't think it was a
principled set of activities but that's
another story
if you want to learn computer science
just you know knuth
wrote the book buy it okay uh you know
read it
and do the problems for if you really
think you know this thing
if you want to learn physics feynman
wrote the book uh
just read the damn book it's all there
so that
when we put stuff online it we don't
have anything in online physics that's
any better than
feynman's book honest honestly now it's
a little easier to learn
uh you know the guy makes jokes every 20
minutes or at least tries to
uh and he does more demos and things so
learning is a weird social phenomena
and so you know our foundation our big
problem is that
the group that does the worst with
online learning are low-income
students because their notion of why am
i learning
their sense of self-confidence the
ability to figure out oh i just got
stuck
because you know two minuses cancel out
and i i never
saw that notation before they just hit
dead ends
all the time that if you're sitting in
your dorm at stanford
you know somebody walks down and uh
helps you get through it
when i started microsoft i didn't think
of it as all that risky i mean i was so
excited about what we were doing
it's true i could have gone bankrupt uh
but
you know i had a set of skills that were
highly employable
and in fact my parents were still
willing to let me go back to harvard and
finish my
education if i wanted to you've always
got a job with babylon
and the only the thing that was scary to
me wasn't quitting and starting the
company it was when i started hiring my
friends
and they expected to be paid
and then we had customers who went
bankrupt customers that i'd counted on
to come through and so then i got this
incredibly conservative approach that i
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay
a year's worth of payroll uh even if we
didn't get any
any payments coming in and you know i'm
almost uh
true to that the whole time we have
about 10 billion now which is is pretty
much enough for the next year
anyway you know i if you're gonna start
a company it takes so much
energy that you know you it better
overcome your
your feeling of risk i don't think
that you necessarily if you're going to
start a company should do it at the
start of your career i think there's a
lot to be said for working for a company
learning how they do things you know if
you're young it's hard to go lease
premises they they made that hard for me
you couldn't rent a car
uh when you were under 25 at the time so
i was always taking taxis to go see
customers
and the people
you know people say we're going to go
have a discussion in the bar well i
couldn't go to the bar
and but you know that's fun because i'll
tell you
when people are first skeptical and they
go this kid doesn't know anything
then when you show them you've really
got a good product and you know
something they actually tend to go
overboard and they think whoa
you know they know a lot uh let's really
do
an incredible amount with these people
so our youth at least in this country
uh was a huge asset for us once we
reached
a certain threshold it is hard it's hard
to hire old
older people um because they'll be a
little bit conservative about
whether they should come and take the
risk and
it took three or four years before we
could go out into the normal
sort of employment pool but those those
problems that come with starting the
firm you better
think of those as as part of the the
pleasure part of the the challenge that
that is part of the the excitement also
if you want to have more self-confidence
and self-belief check out my 254 series
where every day for the next 254 days
i will send you an unlisted video the
sign says it takes up to 254 days
of consecutive action build a habit so
i'm going to be with you every step of
the way
if you want to be on for free 100 free
is the link below
go check it out i'll see you there you
really have to believe the internet's
going to be mainstream
when you have the level of success that
we've had when you have a business
that's important as this with this many
competitors
you're going to have people saying some
nasty things if you ask
people across the united states is the
future
going to be better than the past most
say
no throughout our history we wake
every day knowing that in the business
of technology
you have to think about what are you
missing what is the research or customer
feedback
that you should be paying more attention
to and how do you keep that pace of
innovation
very very high how do you make sure
you're hiring the very best people
and that kind of focus has has helped
drive us forward through all the
milestones the company has had
certainly the internet is is a great
example of that we had to
tear up our our plans and and step back
and say
well how do we how do we really embrace
all that's good about the internet and
recognize some of the shortcomings and
make sure we're leading the way
in reducing what what has held people
away from the internet
computers when i was young were super
expensive
and my friend paul allen and i actually
snuck into
places at the university of washington
where they had computers that weren't
being used at night
and so we were fascinated by what the
computer could do
but very few people were getting
exposure we had to go
out of our way and we were lucky that we
did it all
and so then when the idea of moving the
computer onto a
chip that intel would make and that
would make the computer
literally millions of times cheaper than
the ones we were using so both more
powerful and available
to people on a personal level then the
idea of okay
it would be very different the software
you needed the way the industry would
work
we were super lucky to
be there when that was happening so what
did your family think
did they say there's something wrong
with this young man he wants to just do
computers
they knew i was obsessed with computers
that i would
skip athletics that i'd go in overnight
that i'd
you know leave the house sometimes when
they prefer i went go
work at night on these things and so it
was kind of considered a little strange
and the big moment was when i said
instead of going to
part of my senior year that i wanted to
go work uh
for company writing software so they
were great about
allowing that to be my hobby you are
here with your daughter who is
21 right and you were 21 when you became
a billionaire
is that right almost yeah all right so
around that age you were you were like
the youngest person to become a
billionaire
is that right yeah in terms of my own
earning it on my own yeah right okay so
which is the most important thing yeah
so did you when you were a kid did you
did you care about money or you just
cared about technology and that's it
just happened
uh mostly i love software uh i do
remember the private school i went to
there were other kids whose families
were better off
like they had a porsche or something but
it wasn't that that big of a deal
my thing was that i just loved doing
software i loved hiring people
and i was stunned when it ended up being
so valuable
really yeah you it surprised you yeah
because i always had to be careful that
we wouldn't hire too many people i was
always worried because i was
people who worked for me were older than
me and they had kids and i always
thought what if we don't get paid
will i be able to meet the payroll so i
was always very conservative
about the finances and then when we did
go
uh public uh was i uh
30 by then uh then i was kind of stunned
at what it multiplied out to
if you suddenly found yourself to be uh
say a sophomore in college
at harvard what do you think you would
study and how do you think you'd
spend your time engaging in activities
well the thing that you're likely to be
world class at
is whatever you obsessed over from say
age 12
to 18. you know in my case it was
writing software
uh where i would think i was good and
then i would meet somebody who would
tell me i wasn't and
i would look at their code and i went
through four sort of comeuppances
of oh that's what a really good
programmer looks like and part of the
reason i worship digital equipment was
eventually it was a couple of their very
best programmers
who came and shared with me how they
thought about how they did thing and i
had studied their code and
uh and that and there there were several
people who were
so key to my doing that so today
i would go into you know software which
today
that means going into artificial
intelligence uh
you know computers still can't read they
they cannot take a book of information
and say pass an ap test on that book
and that's a solvable problem but it's a
knowledge representation problem
and you know i've always wanted to solve
that problem uh i'm jealous
that maybe one of you gets to work on
that
i'm you know unlikely to go back and be
hands on in that
in that way but it's the juiciest
problem ever i've thought about it for a
long time
uh so i would go into ai urgency
that i felt that if we didn't get
microsoft going right away that somebody
uh would do a great job building a
software company we won't have a chance
that probably
ended up not being true that i could
have waited two or three years
and the opportunity to do microsoft
still would be there but anyway i felt a
sense of urgency uh
and you know it's not like you know i
still get to take courses and learn
things um today you know things like the
learning company and there's all sorts
of great books so
it's not like i've missed some part of
my education
when you dropped out your father and
mother said are you sure you know what
you want to do if
one of your children dropped out of
college to start a company what would
you say
well i'd have to say yes but the
dropping out is not an irrevocable
decision
uh you know if you try and start a
company it doesn't go well they always
let you go back
uh and so if you don't have
you know kids that you need to uh
support
you know it's a very low risk thing
particularly in the
culture of the united states where
trying to start something and
unveiling is not a black mark for the
rest of your life
you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream
a lot of people are going to get out
there and use it and that they're going
to be
willing to pay for some content is that
the operating idea
that you have well each of these
businesses
is an entrepreneurial business the
overreaching theme is that yes i believe
in the internet i believe it'll get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that
is you've got a lot of cash on hand yes
right all right it puts you in an
envelope position you can experiment
with a lot of entrepreneurial ideas
and see what sticks and what flies well
we're we're in business to make money
and but the other thing is providing
such a cash flow for you
well it all belongs to the shareholders
uh we're not dilating no i know
we are business people and it is true
that
if you find an idea that requires
three or four years of improvement and
patience
and really sticking with it that we're
very good at that
take windows which we bet our company on
everybody who doubted that would succeed
ibm did not support us in that it took
longer than we expected over four years
before finally graphical interface got
popular
and now people take it for granted it's
part of every personal computer and you
just
you just expect it to be there that was
one of the grand successes of the
company
in the same way we're betting on the
internet that our tools there will be
popular
and that a few of these content plays
that we've decided to get involved in
that the scale and and the users will
make those into
great businesses i like to look at
numbers a lot and so when i look at the
numbers i'm just amazed whether it's
the quality of the inner city education
the dropout rates
oprah did a thing where she had kids
from an inner city school go look at the
suburban school and vice versa and they
were just stunned that the
building and everything was so
completely
different so i think you know even for
me i have to
go you know whether it's the inner city
in america talking to people
who live there or outside the us we have
this same thing
you know the situation in africa you
know it's overwhelmingly
uh black population is so much worse
than people are probably aware of and so
hands-on visits
whether it's to the schools or the
clinics i think that
is necessary to hear the voices of
people who've been hurt
and then you know there's a lot of good
movies now there's a lot of good books i
was just reading the new jim crow which
is pretty
eloquent and forceful about the justice
system and the role that it plays
in perpetuating bad conditions and
you know it takes a lot to try and put
yourself having
empathy for other people so we all have
to push harder on this
today people come to you all the time
for money
i assume everywhere you go people say by
the way i have this thing you should
invest in but i have a couple of myself
i'll mention later no i'm not just
kidding
no a couple things you should invest in
or things you give money to so how do
you resist that you have some person who
says no for you
or how do you do that let many people uh
many people say no
well once you picked what you care about
if somebody has something that can make
a difference in global health
we're super interested in you know we
have staff of 1500 people
and if it's to do with global health
some of those people will come out and
talk through with you whatever your
innovation is and how we can partner
with you on that
you know so that's clearly in our area
if it is something that can
substantially improve k-12 education
then we're
going to be very interested in it if
people are asking outside of those
things then
you know fortunately you can say no
because focus is
is key to philanthropy the digital
revolution internet social media all of
that
in certain respects it's made it easier
for us to see what's going on medical
researchers are publishing articles
every day
and all over the world people can
immediately see what the new thinking is
there
tracking the disease statistics i click
on the john hopkins website
every morning and see okay which
countries are having a tough time with
cases or deaths thank god for the
internet
work at home in our ability to connect
up with each other is driven by that but
it also
has meant that a lot of very
surprisingly
interesting conspiracy theories that are
false
sadly they spread a lot faster than the
truth you know so the idea that
did somebody intentionally cause this
thing completely false
even in some cases accusing me of having
some connection
that can be dangerous because it means
you know your willingness to believe
is the vaccine something i should take
should i wear masks
you know if you go for these simple but
wrong theories getting people to work
together
and protect each other so we can get out
of this as soon as possible
that's really at risk you raise the
question of
how should the government deal with that
it's very difficult
ideally citizens are just well informed
and they know which publications
are very careful about what they say and
we don't have to engage in
censorship but so much of the almost
crazy false information is out there
that looking at the companies like
facebook and saying okay what is their
role in that you know when somebody says
masks don't work which is wrong or they
say just take
hydroxychloroquine and you'll be totally
safe what is their responsibility for
catching
those things particularly when they get
out to large numbers that is being
debated
and you know i think we'll come out of
this with those companies feeling a
stronger sense of responsibility and
actually understanding having the public
debate
about uh how they need to help here the
idea that you could get people to to
decide
to support this foreign aid thing which
is a big deal
for our foundation from a numeric point
of view we're still
pushing that a little bit but honestly
the story of the one child
you know if you say to an audience
here's the picture of the child shall we
save this child
they're more engaged than if you said
hey let's save a million children
you know so there's definitely a sort of
you know 10 to the sixth
problem uh here somewhere
humans are not wired uh
to be to do that on a numeric basis
um and so you know that's why we have
people like bono
and and many others who come from a more
storytelling
world and then they let me throw a few
charts and numbers in
uh because i think uh that that should
should be there once your heart tells
you what direction to go in
to prove that this is a a very
affordable
not you know not a big deal well-managed
path to
to be on we think uh that progress
can actually accelerate the last last 15
years have been wonderful but the next
15
uh we can do more uh and
some people worry that when you you talk
about progress that it'll
uh reduce people's commitment to make
things better
uh they think when you talk about
progress that it shows you're naive and
that maybe you don't realize
uh all those things that are left to be
done and how
horrific they are uh and you know so
sometimes that
purely that negative side of the story
gets told but
you lose something very important uh if
you
only look at it that way you lose the
optimism about
what's possible and you lose the
information
where you look at the places that have
done better than others and you
understand
what is it about delivery innovation
partnerships caring what has come
together
for the very best progress and then
spread that
to the other places that's what will
help us drive
at full speed i feel like you always
seem to swing for the fences in general
it's just sort of a new way of framing
it but i have to ask if you are swinging
for the fences
what if you miss well hopefully uh you
get more than one swings
either at the same problem like you know
multiple malaria vaccine constructs so
that you know if you have two or three
the combined chance of success is much
higher or that you're working in
multiple areas
not just one area right you know in
climate for example have a company
that's
uh trying to make a nuclear reactor
that would be very cheap and that would
have safety so that
the public would be very accepting of it
now you know even i realize that's
high risk you know less than 50 percent
chance all that comes together and yet
uh if it did
and the only reason i'm involved is it
would really help with climate
let us generate electricity without any
greenhouse gases
you went to harvard and you dropped out
have you ever thought how your life
could be better off if you had gotten
your harvard degree
well i i'm a weird dropout because i
take college courses all the time
i love uh learning company courses and
and things so i loved being a student
and
there were smart people around and you
know they fed you
and they gave you these nice grades that
made you feel smart
uh so i i feel it was unfortunate
uh that i didn't get to stay there but i
don't think i missed
any knowledge because you know whatever
i needed to learn i would
i was still in a learning mode
historically
the newspapers or the the media
were very responsible about not letting
uh untruths about vaccine safety get out
there
now you know you don't want to get rid
of the good thing which is that anybody
can publish
the barriers to entry the diversity of
voices
is so phenomenal compared to to
traditional publishing
right i feel like and you have a bit of
a youtube presence so you're able to
share
information about things uh through
social media it's kind of a social media
age so i feel like that
ideally helps your cause more than it
hurts it yeah my audience
probably isn't uh deep with the vaccine
doubters
yeah yeah you know i
in a creative way uh trying to get
positive messages to uh be interesting
and we have work to do on that you know
i would have thought
using experts on scientific knowledge
that the
all the internet would just make it so
much easier to learn about things
uh and yet in some ways uh
you know people aren't seeking out
complex information
particularly if it disagrees uh
with some preconceived notion that they
have so you know how can
social media get out there and be a
little bit of a
uh force for education particularly on
climate where
without a consensus we won't do the
the hard things that will
save things for the next generation when
you were starting microsoft there were a
lot of other
software companies and you were not
number one at the beginning i think
there were mothers who were
a little bit further ahead what was it
that enabled you to beat everybody else
up
in the software business was it bill
gates was it something else what was the
unique factor that made you the most
successful
yeah we were actually the first and but
there were companies
uh and they were all kind of single
product companies
who got ahead of us uh in terms of sales
you know by uh
about 1991 uh we
we did become the largest uh
of all of them we were an engineering
company we were about
how you hire smart people and how you
use tools to develop software broadly
we were global and we weren't about a
single product
so like for example word perfect was a
word processor
somebody might remember they did so well
with that product that their gross sales
rivaled ours when we were doing a broad
set of products
as soon as graphics interface caught on
which was windows
uh that became mainstream in 1995 we
became far
larger than the other software companies
now subsequently
uh you know google apple
uh amazon have become uh
you know also extremely successful but
in the 90s
we were the strongest uh
okay by far when you have a tragedy like
this pandemic
there is always the possibility you're
going to
narrow your community that you care
about
you're going to think about yourself
your family not the whole country
including
those who've been been somewhat left
behind likewise there's a risk
looking at africa and other developing
countries and say no we need to help
them out because
difficulties there of not enough food
are really extreme and
small amounts of the budget less than
one percent can help them out
likewise you don't want to just think
about the here and now you also want to
think about the future after all
the government failed us by not
anticipating this pandemic
there were voices like mine in ted talk
and other venues that
kind of said hey get ready we don't know
when but it's coming
sadly that didn't happen another thing
we
trust government to get us ready for is
climate change
that's coming and it won't be as easy as
creating a vaccine to solve it
and so right now terms of people's
sympathy
being broad you know being willing to
address other problems even though
they're not
here right now i am actually seeing a
lot of positive voices people saying
make sure the recovery is a green
recovery europe
has done a lot on that and so and
actually the dialogue
in politics about you know does climate
change matter
is stronger today than it's ever been so
this closing in
and only worrying about the short term
i'm not seeing that
of course your audience which is very
young will be the key
to saying let's not just look at this
short term
let's start the investments that deal
with inequities let's start the
investments that can make sure
climate change doesn't come in and and
have even more tragic results than this
pandemic does
young people thinking about policies
getting
involved i think i'm seeing an uptick i
hope that's sustained
because they're you know they're the
ones who will really do the innovative
work
part of the thing that drives computer
science forward is
is doing risky things having a long-term
time
horizon and when microsoft was a small
company we benefited from the fact that
a t and xerox and other companies had
made
investments in research that they'd
reached out and worked
with universities on a broad basis so we
felt very lucky that as we got
to a certain level of success we could
start our own research group
and have that research group be in
partnership with top universities all
over the world doing
advanced programming programs things
that range from
the work on speech recognition all the
way up to quantum computing
we have a fairly serious program that
has a you know high risk of failure
uh which makes it fun and interesting on
quantum computing and you know even in
the best case it's probably a decade
away before that
makes a difference but that's the kind
of thing that when it works can happen
got to know each other we would uh
be traveling around lagos where the
traffic gives you lots of time to sit
and talk
sometimes and you know i'd be showing a
leak of my charts about hey
sokoto has a pretty low vaccination rate
uh you know and kano needs to do this
and
in aleko he really knows people he has
relationships he's willing to reach out
to people so he'd say hey
let's call the governor you know we'll
talk to him about this
and sure enough you know next thing you
know we've got the governor of dakota on
the phone we're talking about
uh this and so this ability now to reach
out to draw on the the
broad relationships uh that elico's
developed and
you know i'm pretty shy about calling
people i just want to mail them
my chart but in fact
uh what's come out of that is that alico
and i do
a video conference call with six of the
governors in the northern states
where uh twice a year we look at uh
vaccine coverage you know is the supply
chain working are the workers showing up
or the
healthcare posts in the right locations
and it's a big challenge but uh
really drawing on aliko's communication
skills and the fact that he's not afraid
to call anyone
everybody wants to talk to him uh it's
it's been phenomenal
the idea that computers were going to be
a change agent
and i was lucky enough to meet paul
allen
and early on we brainstormed about this
i did the ship
and the chip changed the rules i mean
most things don't get a million times
better
not you know engine efficiency or
uh you know most things have uh
theoretical minimums
computation is something that uh we're
not even close to the theoretical
minimum and yet
we've improved so much so seeing that
that was going to come
and weirdly that most people didn't see
that was going to come so
you know even people at ibm were still
thinking in terms of big computers
you know now all the the uh software and
service driven companies are worth even
more than ibm
when i was growing up ibm was the
monolith and it was always okay
are we going to beat them are we going
to join them those bastards
they were very nice people but we always
thought of them uh
and they they sort of stood for these
big computers that only big companies
and governments could get
the benefit for so actually we played
off of that to have this
power to the people personal computing
type thing of course now we're a big
company
and somebody can play off of us the idea
that a young person can start a company
here
is a super nice thing because although
people at first are skeptical
as soon as they realize their normal
model of what i knew and what i could do
that i didn't fit that normal
model then they assumed i knew way more
than i did and i could solve all sorts
of problems i had no clue
uh you know how to solve but you know it
was nice
uh that people were kind of a gog that
we had built this company and done these
things
from a young age so i think the culture
of america that you know
almost the american dream type success
story if you want to have
impact uh usually delegation is
important
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started
i wrote most the code and everybody
else's code i read and kind of rewrote
and that got us up to 10 people
and then i had to say to myself okay
we're going to ship code that i didn't
edit
and that was hard for me uh but you know
i kind of got over that then
i still said okay i'm going to interview
everyone and i'm going to at least look
at samples of their code well that got
us up to about 40 people
and that was at a point where i had sold
way more software than we could write
because everybody was so impressed and i
thought
well i need to keep enough collect
enough money
to you know keep hiring all these people
but
uh the demand was so high that you know
we were actually
falling behind that's when i hired steve
and steve
figured out a uh how to control
what promises i made to people and b how
to hire lots of people
and good really good people and create
organizations and teams so i delegated
to steve
that and he was constantly saying to me
okay we're gonna hire programmers that
you've never met and i'd say no or not
and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't gonna work
uh you know so uh then i said okay then
i would you know know all the managers
of the people and so over time
uh and of course you know i could say
the quality per person was falling
monotonically uh
uh according to me uh
but you know large problems uh
if you want to you know write the most
popular office productivity software
that one person absolutely can't do that
you can write pretty code so
everyone has to decide what scale of
organization they want to
work in eventually you know my role was
very much as a leader
and a reviewer of managers but the top
people and i hired some super
experienced people
uh i would make sure they were pursuing
a common vision and they were well
coordinated
but in terms of a lot of management
stuff
they were way better than i was now i
had to have the framework
to know what mix of skills that we
needed and
you know when they were working well
enough together but
a lot of uh you know my
value-added was picking say to do
graphics user interface or to do an
integrated office
uh type thing or to go global and not
use agents to have microsoft be present
all over the world
and so yeah picking what you're good at
and how you find the other people
to fill in those things that's super
important and most founders don't
aren't able to scale that up and kind of
give up the hands-on things that they
used to get a lot of
pleasure and comfort from if you ask
people across the united states
is the future going to be better than
the past
most say no my kids will be worse off
than i
am they think innovation
won't make the world better for them or
their children
so who's right the people who say
innovation will create new possibilities
and make the
world better or the people who see a
trend toward
inequality and a decline in opportunity
and don't think innovation will change
that
the pessimists are wrong in my view
but they're not crazy if innovation
is purely market driven and we don't
focus on the big inequities
then we could have amazing advances in
inventions
that leave the world even more divided
we won't improve public schools we won't
cure malaria
we won't end poverty we won't develop
the innovations poor farmers need to
grow food
in a changing climate if our
optimism doesn't address the problems
that affect so many of our fellow human
beings
then our optimism needs more empathy
if empathy channels our optimism
we will see the poverty and the disease
and the poor schools
we will answer with our innovations and
we will surprise
the pessimists over the next generation
you stanford graduates will lead a new
wave of innovation
which problems will you decide to solve
if your world is wide you can create the
future we all want
if your world is narrow you may create
the future
the pesticide started learning insueto
that if we're going to make our optimism
matter to everyone
and empower people everywhere we have to
see the lives of those most in need
if we have optimism without empathy then
it doesn't matter how much we master the
secrets of science
we're not really solving problems we're
just working on puzzles
i think most of you have a broader world
view
than i had at your age you can do better
at this
than i did if you put your hearts and
minds to it
you can surprise the pessimists
we're eager to see it i decided to
to focus more on uh giving away than
than making money and so i've
uh gotten a chance to travel the world
be out in africa and asia quite a bit
and see the needs that are out there
and now our foundation is very focused
on global health
focused on agriculture because the
majority of the the very poor in the
world are farmers who have
very small plots of land so any increase
in productivity or
certainty of their crop coming in can
make huge difference for them
and you might think of a career in
software
you know selling to uh people who can
afford personal computers and now
uh the career at the foundation is being
very different and certainly they're
different in the sense that now it's
about vaccines now a lot it's it's with
various
uh governments uh the donor governments
the governments and
import countries but at its core it's
really
basically the same thing which is uh
finding innovators people who've got
breakthrough ideas
uh be willing to back them understand
what they're working on
measure what they're coming up with uh
try and make sure that when it's
delivered it really has the impact it's
supposed to be in getting into a
feedback loop driven by
a very precise measurement we felt a
little bad
i i certainly i did about leaving the
university
when uh i thought very interesting work
on artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now
you know it's taken a long time the rate
of progress which is hard to make
numeric
in both those areas has been quite
modest i mean we haven't gone backwards
or anything but
ai is turned out to be a tougher problem
which is
is fascinating and now there there are
some interesting
advances and likewise symbolic type
things
there are some now advances so we
thought we'd miss
uh being more at the center of those now
through at least funding microsoft
research
we get to have some level of involvement
in that
one of paul's ideas was to build a 360
emulator that was the dominant mainframe
of the time use bit slice
architecture to just you know blow away
the pricing
on mainframe computing but we decided
that was kind of boring
uh compared to personal computing a
company came along about five years
later two pi
and did it they didn't do the software
piece right that's why they failed
because we still think it was a good
idea but we didn't have anything even
close to
hey let's build the computer that we
want to use that we want to have as a
tool for our own
messing around and communication and
creativity that
that kind of got at the center of our
thinking even from
the early days and when i was young i
had to read the world books sort of
alphabetically
and it didn't have any videos you could
click on and it was
you know it's weird to learn things
alphabetically it's kind of hard to
create
quite the same framework as you can with
all these great online materials
uh and so i think the empowerment now
you know the opportunity to see what's
going on whether it's in fields of
science or
uh in places that are far away including
else most need it's never been so great
it's a wonderful time
to be a student now software in terms of
letting us simulate things
whether it's scientific phenomena or
social phenomena
it's getting better and better and so i
think
almost any major that you have nowadays
understanding you know what software how
it's going to change those activities
is a key part of of being at the cutting
edge we're going to test your knowledge
of some everyday items that you get at
the supermarket when's the last time
that you have been
at a supermarket long time ago okay
all right this will be interesting all
right if you can guess three out of the
five uh
products within a dollar of each one uh
the price
the audience will get something okay
if you get all of them we'll pay off
your children's student loans
no no danger there yeah
all right which is going to be our prize
model um and here we go
there is rice-a-roni right there
the san francisco treat of course how
much do you think
rice-a-roni would be within a dollar hmm
five dollars okay let's
the audience didn't like that let's see
oh it's a dollar look what a bargain
i'll take five i know
all right okay tide pods you've been
hearing a lot about those lately
what do you think four dollars
no no they want they want me to go
higher yeah let's go with 10
10 10 all right
19.97 it's expensive to do laundry
i'll take a half it's a very costly
okay now very important this is my best
choice
really one yeah because you floss
absolutely yeah
i floss as well it's very important to
keep your gums in good health
all right that's floss
how much would you say that floss i
would say four dollars oh
look at you 378
i think you know you can over
worship and mythologize the idea of
working extremely hard
for my particular makeup i mean
it really is true that i didn't believe
in weekends i didn't believe in
vacations i mean
you know i knew everybody's license
plate so i could tell you over the last
month when their car had come and gone
from
the parking lot is so i don't recommend
it eh
i don't think most people would enjoy it
uh once i got into my 30s i could hardly
even imagine how i had done that uh
because by then some natural behavior
kicked in and i loved weekends and
uh you know my girlfriend liked
vacations and that turned out to be
kind of a neat thing
now i take lots of vacations my 20 year
old self is so
disgusted with my uh current uh
uh self you know i i was sure i would
never do anything but riding coach you
know now i have a plane so it's
it's very much counter revelations have
taken place
at high speed but yes it is nice
if during those first several years
if you have a team that's chosen to be
pretty
maniacal about the company and how far
that goes you
should have a mutual understanding so
you're not uh one person expecting one
thing another person to expect another
thing
and you'll have individuals who who have
you know
health or relatives or things that are
distracted but yes i
have a fairly hardcore view that there
should be a very large
uh sacrifice made during those
those early years i think the the
quality
that uh has helped me in lots of things
is a kind of measurement
scientific framework where i go in and
say
did anybody handle this well what are
the very best practices
do we have numbers on that and let's get
everybody
measuring what they're doing and so they
can strive to
match what that the best achievement is
for us often that's something like
getting the vaccines out to all the
children
some very poor countries do that
extremely well because they get down to
that local level and measure the
activity they make sure the inventory's
there they make sure the workers are
showing up
so for me i always uh look at how can we
do better
better measurement and use that to drive
the very best practices today the
greatest pleasure of your life is
when you're doing what is it other than
being interviewed by me or something
like that what are the great
greatest pleasure of your life uh you
know
time with kids time with scientists
time when i'm reading and things are
making sense
you know going out and seeing the impact
of the foundation's work
meeting with scientists who think we can
make breakthroughs to
uh help solve climate uh you know these
are
super interesting problems
and you know having a broad set of
system thinking applied to these
problems
is going to be necessary uh to
orchestrate the resources and policies
behind them so
you know i love i love my work how would
you define
your strengths and your weaknesses how
you can you know incorporate those into
a team kind of
aspect well i'm not somebody who knows a
lot about marketing
you know i wouldn't enjoy being a
salesman for a position where you're
actually
creating the products and thinking
through what those features should be
i'm fascinated by that i've followed the
history
of the industry read about the mistakes
that have been made
so product definition product creation
very strong
if you have a team that understands the
customers the sales the marketing i'm
not going to bring that
but i i would enjoy working with them so
if you were
uh 20 years old today and you wanted to
start a new company drop out of
harvard what company or what area would
you want to start it in
well this is a great time to be doing
innovation because the tools of
innovation are so much better
there are lots of things in biology that
are very interesting
uh there are lots of things in energy
that are interesting
given my background i would start an ai
company
that whose goal would be to
teach computers how to read so that they
can absorb and understand
all the written knowledge of the world
that's an area where ai
has yet to make progress and it will be
quite profound when we achieve that goal
and so i get to when i you know say okay
we're going to build a
tb drug team we're going to build the tb
vaccine team we're going to build them
you know kill all the mosquitoes in the
world gene drive
crispr team i get to
in terms of how we fund that organize it
how many locations
do we wait till they have this result
before we scale it up
i get to use the same uh
or 80 percent the same type of thinking
that i exercised in terms of
okay let's go do windows let's go do
excel
so it's backing engineers it's getting a
sense of the team
you know what needs to be added to that
team or the iqs on the team
adding up uh as opposed to subtracting
from each other
and it's very comfortable because the
the most intense period
of microsoft was where these teams were
about size 30
and for our diseases you know typhoid
rotavirus
there's a lot of diseases uh that
hopefully you'll never hear of again
uh most of which don't exist here in the
u.s but
so it is very very similar it takes a
decade
generally from start to finish the aids
vaccine actually were on year 14 and
it'll probably be another eight to ten
years before that one is completely done
so some take as long as
as 20 years because there's many
dead ends and you have kind of a
portfolio of approaches but yes i feel
like
my working with governments hiring smart
people
managing teams it did prepare me well
for this very
operational organization
that's a lot like a business except that
we're our profit is live
saved as opposed to a monetary
measure how do you retain your optimism
it's great that people are worried about
the problems
uh because they require action
you know even take inequity globally
inequity is down that is
the poor countries are getting richer
faster than the richer countries are
getting richer right the
bulk of humanity lives in middle income
countries today
if you go back 50 years there were
very very few middle income countries it
was pretty bi-modal where he had
india and china africa were poor and
then
europe us japan's starting to be
fairly well-off and not much in the
middle but today
china's at the high end of middle income
india indus at the low on the middle
income brazil
indonesia it's a it's a phenomenal story
and the ability of science to solve
problems uh you know clearly in the case
of
heart disease and cancer make a lot of
progress
some of the more chronic diseases like
depression diabetes
i'm optimistic even obesity uh
you know we're gaining some fundamental
understandings of
the microbiome and the signaling
mechanisms
involved in these things so yes i am
optimistic
it does bother me that that most people
aren't optimistic
and you know so one of us is wrong
this is right most people over the last
200 years or so whoever they the
wealthiest person in the world was
didn't usually work that hard when they
got to be 60 or so they kind of
took life easy you seem to be working
pretty hard what motivates you to still
work so hard well i love
my work the work of the foundation is
super interesting i get to meet with the
scientists i get to go out
in the field i do think your habits are
sort of set
in your 20s and 30s and
by my standards of the 20s well you know
i didn't believe in weekends back then
uh not to mention vacations so i'm you
know fairly lazy compared to myself in
my 20s
where i was a true uh fanatic uh
you know all i believed in was working
on software
night and day and and for my 20s that
was perfect i didn't have a wife or
family
uh at all and my role was very
hands-on role in the early days you know
you were just a college dropout you were
very young looking
did you get taken seriously by
businessmen who are much older
for some people that youth uh
and geekiness was like hey
should we trust them you know that's so
weird we've never seen something like
that before
so yes we had to fight for acceptance i
couldn't rent cars
uh so i had to take cabs around because
i was
too young and you know probably some
people were a little top but
then as as we got a little bit of
success people were fascinated by
this deep belief we had in in software
knowing that you're doing all this work
but someone in my position
i'm not a philanthropist i don't
necessarily have the means how does
someone like me or someone watching this
help in the best way they can well i
wish more people could actually
get to these countries you know uh join
the peace corps spend time even
uh just spending a few weeks there and
see how great the needs are and see the
progress
a lot of uh you know volunteer work
in the united states builds that sense
of okay we care about other humans even
you know beyond our own uh family group
even people had very different
experiences
so you know at a young age a little bit
of giving money away
you know to form that habit and picking
which things you really want to give to
including
lots of things here in the us and
getting involved with volunteer time
those are the people
uh who i think will help kind of bring
the world together and
you know avoid uh just this divisiveness
uh that is is my greatest concern
you know in microsoft my early partner
was paul allen and then steve ballmer
uh was my partner now melinda's uh you
know even
a totally equal partner in all the
foundation work we're doing
so she she and i run it together it was
so fascinating i mean the relationships
we were building
learning all this new stuff to have
somebody to brainstorm with about it
uh you know made it a lot more fun
you know things like writing letters
together giving speeches together we had
to learn
how to bring out the best of the both of
us and in doing those things but yeah it
was always
you know clear we wanted to do it
together let's say you're interviewing
for
a junior engineer position at microsoft
sitting in a boardroom or
on video call in 2020 why should we hire
you
you should look at the code that i've
written you know i'm kind of crazy i
write software programs way beyond any
classes that i've taken
and think i've gotten better over time
so take a look at how ambitious i've
been there
i do think i can work well with people i
might criticize their code a little
harshly but overall
i like to be on a team i like ambitious
goals
i like thinking through how we can
anticipate the future
software is cool and i want to be
involved as usual if you have
you know negative consequences for
mistakes it kind of discourages that
completing the loop type system there
are a few cases like in
in civil aviation where the
willingness to look at mistakes and
apply massive
resources like we're seeing today to say
okay
what went wrong here it really is pretty
mind-blowing
there's no doubt that the anti-trust
lawsuit was bad for microsoft
and if we would have been more focused
on
creating the uh phone operating system
and so instead of using android today
you would be using windows mobile if it
hadn't been for the honor trust case
uh microsoft would go oh we were so
close we we you know
i was just too distracted i screwed that
up uh because of the distraction
and you know we were just three months
too late with the release that motorola
would have used on a phone
uh so yes uh it's a winner take all game
that is for sure
that you know now nobody here's ever
heard of windows mobile
uh but oh well and i wouldn't
uh that's a few hundred billion here and
there
uh i wouldn't have retired as soon
and that one is less you know i am
disappointed that windows mobile didn't
succeed but in terms of
uh my own life you know even though it
was a very painful thing
because i got very personally involved
in the defense of the company
the fact that i retired earlier probably
net was good for me because i got
down the learning curve on the
foundation i got to partner with melinda
in the early days of the foundation
and you know i don't have a life where
i'm allowed to complain
uh because basically you know only 99
of things have worked out very very well
i'm very lucky that my foundation work
the part-time work i do for microsoft i
see that extending you know for decades
into the future and having an
understanding of innovation
uh you know i think shaping innovation
in many of these areas there is a unique
role that i can
i can help play the nice thing now that
i'm not uh so extreme in my 20s i
i didn't get to read uh much at all
and so like all this stuff was going on
in biology and math
um i just didn't didn't get to read it
then when i did get into my 30s
those vacations were uh a time to
go back uh because when i was a student
you know you could study all sorts of
things uh
anyway um now
you know i read a lot of science uh and
that
uses up uh you know maybe half of the
slots
uh that that i have
really understanding us poverty and
what's going on there there's a
a few dozen books that try and give you
a glimpse of that that are very good
this book facts on this let me say you
know it definitely
uh creates a framing
uh for what's going on in the world and
the other one that's right up there is
any uh pinker book
starting with uh uh better angels of our
nature
the key thing was that paul allen and i
had loved working on software since we
were lucky enough to be exposed
literally i was 13 and 8th grade when
this time sharing terminal came in and
we just
did it day and night and you know got
better and we could see
that the magic of software combined with
this miracle of the microprocessor
subject to moore's law
exponential improvement that that was a
magic combination and we we'd look
around and say hey how come everybody's
not
saying this is amazing i mean we're
gonna dethrone ibm
and uh you know why doesn't digital
equipment get it why is the guy who runs
it this is a company that's long gone
uh but dominated many computers at the
time why isn't that guy up there saying
it's it's wrong we know it's right
and so the key event for us was it was a
very cold
boston winter and a kid computer came
out on
uh this popular electronics magazine and
we said oh
damn this is happening without us i mean
here we are
uh doing nothing and so we called the
company up and said
you know hey we're ready uh and then we
called them back
we actually did the work and then we
called them back and said how do you
make the
stuff go in and out of the computer the
i o
and they said well that's interesting
nobody else has ever asked that you must
really be doing something so that was
anyway our very first customer and so we
grabbed on to it
to be the very first and we were the
first to say there should be a software
industry
and come and do it in a sense it was one
of the lower risk things i've ever done
in my life because
you know i could have always gone back
uh you know what
my parents my dad didn't say hey if you
go away for a few years i'll stop paying
for your education they were nice and
said okay go
you know learn your lesson down there in
the desert and uh
and you get back to the serious stuff
and you know we're still
we're still waiting there's no doubt
that uh you know creating a board
having people like dave marquart there
who
wasn't at the company you know and we
were so overwrought about
you know this is right this is wrong we
messed this up that
having people have a little bit of
distance uh
come in and talk to us is good you know
for the last
uh oh 30 years or so
i've gotten to be friends with warren
buffett and he
he's in omaha uh he's not in this tech
world at all
you know and to him it's like hey how
could you ever know which
will rise and which will fall i'm not
going to put money
uh until apple sold at a multiple of 12
then
he decided he could put 50 billion into
that
after he asked all his friends hey you
know if the if somebody had an
uh iphone that was half as expensive
would you switch away
you know or is it more like jewelry
where you really want uh
to to have an iphone and so he decided
that
the those profit streams might not be
eliminated anytime soon anyway he
because he's not
in this world he has a
uh a definite way of looking at things
including this idea of how
uh work should be fun he has made his
work so much fun
that he works more hours than i do
he works six days a week at 88 years old
and he likes to say that he skips to
work every day he he doesn't but
he says that when he was 83 he could
still skip but now he's done
really he can't do it so
having somebody like that you know the
toughest thing i went through was this
anti-trust lawsuit
where you know it didn't seem uh very
predictable
uh and he was a great council during
all of that stuff so getting somebody
who's in successful in another domain
uh but yet kind of a business uh
type mindset anyway for me that that was
a huge gift
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch a video and you get motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place
and how you're going to actually take
action on it you jump to 91
chance of following through and when you
have public accountability and you
commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you i think it's important that we build
that feedback system
now exactly how you do that how much you
connect that up
to the pace system uh you know we need
experimentation
and we can look at these other countries
that have done it there is a move afoot
to do some of this but whether the
investment levels be enough to make it
high quality and whether the
um there'll be kind of high stakes that
overuse the test scores
for this stuff and and will sort of hurt
its reputation
it's hard to say at this point but i'd
say it's giving more feedback to
teachers
would be the very first thing that would
get us
back up to the uh to being one of the
best in the world
if you want some amazing motivation from
elon musk check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there it's uh
not as much fun being me as you'd think
i don't know you don't think so
there's definitely it could be worse for
sure but it's um